with that on the mine forefront I turn
it over to you d-wade you actually have
a project you'd like to talk about in
that same vein I do so I am I'm excited
about this one and I'm proud of this one
you know Carmelo Anthony Chris Paul to
myself we started a social change fund
and it's simple for us is it's a lot
smarter people in this world it's a lot
of people that are in the communities of
color that are doing the work and it's
our responsibility we feel - to uplift
them to bring our resources in our reach
to these communities to these
individuals organizations that are doing
amazing things so we invested in to the
social change fund and we have reached
out to corporations that are giving up
hundreds of millions of dollars you know
for racial inequality and hopefully they
invest into the social change fund and
everything that we're doing but you know
what's important to me is that it's not
just about Carmelo Chris and myself this
is a fund that was created for athletes
entertainers corporations to be a part
of we had a call to action at the ESPYs
in 2011-12 in 2016 to our fellow
athletes and this is us following back
when I call to action and putting
together a plan to go into the
communities of colors in and try to try
to do some good so all the money that
you get donated to front to this Social
Fund you go out and you give it back to
the community and you help people with
resources you help them with skillsets
what are you actually giving the people
yeah we so we have identified a few
pillars you know what a weird focus on I
talked to draymond and Chuck as well
about this what we focused on police
brutality police reform we've we've
looked at different groups and say okay
the bail project this is what you guys
are doing you know they got six or seven
different things that they do and so we
support different organizations that are
already are doing the work that already
have laid the groundwork we're bringing
more resources to them to go
we know what Austrians are and what we
bring into this we're bringing our we
bring in our pocketbook we bring in our
reach we bring in our platform but they
doing the work and we want to make sure
that they have the income and the money
to be able to do the work to to see
change that we all want to see to create
the change that we all want to see I
know you say it's not about you all
because you have big names but you also
have a responsibility and an obligation
and I think it's you know not an
accident that all three of you all are
here tonight and you all have something
that you're working on to give back to
the community